The answer of course is the second one, structure of arrays,
because you're going to have many threads
executing this code snippet at the same time.
In the first case, each thread will be accessing element A from a different place in memory
followed element B and element C and so forth.
Whereas in the second case,
all these threads running at the same time will access adjacent elements.
And remember why this matters?
Because the actual memory, the DRAM that represents the global memory,
accesses data in large chunks or bursts.
So you'll get much better utilization of one of these bursts,
a fixed sized memory transaction,
when you have many threads that are simultaneously trying to access memory
that will be contained within that transaction.